all right for the record I want to get
my April Journal to you guys but the
trailers just keep coming the videos
need to get made nothing like a plain
boat so today we have the first trailer
to it chapter two it's pretty simple
trailer the premise being the losers
Club 26 or 27 years later have come back
to Derry because apparently Pennywise
has come back to Derrick they're gonna
face off against the evil boggart clown
this trailer starts out with Jessica
Chastain who plays Beverly Marsh all
grown up she's in her house I will do
her old house her old house of Derry the
place of her torment the lady who lives
there is apparently this old lady and
she's a little creepy I mean she's a
little awfully obviously there's
something weird going on so she's
probably penny wise who's revealed later
yep penny wise I'm not gonna lie for the
longest time in that conversation there
was nothing that was strictly penny wise
she's like no one ever really dies
you
I thought my phone froze on his way but
gonna be honest that happens when
talking to old people could just be an
old lady doesn't necessarily mean penny
wise it's weird but it does not
necessarily mean psycho shape-shifting
clown that feeds off of fear not proof
that is penny wise running naked through
the living room still might not be penny
wise these are commonalities of the
elderly folks if you haven't been in an
old lady's living room while she streaks
through it and you just haven't lived
penny wise is being held creepy in the
background like when I first watched it
on my phone I didn't notice it then I
watched it on my computer I was like oh
yeah background any wise emulating me on
the dance floor
those are my dance moves and you see the
losers Club all together gander like
alright we got to take this [ __ ] out
we can do this we got to stick together
this just really it's a flash of imagery
with a really creepy giggle I love the
giggle thank you something about these
it trailers that just have weird creepy
sounds so it's once that haunt you in
the middle of the night like this yep
nightmares I love have like just penny
wise on balloons it just ruins childhood
right up is so magical floating on
balloons
oh it won't not anymore I hate balloons
now floating on balloons is not so
magical and serene and at the end we
actually do see penny wise who thought
of it did you think of it he's out of it
[Music]
so they didn't have to show much I think
is the perfect trailer like I want to
see more but I don't want to see more I
know I shouldn't see more it's like
eating cake for breakfast I would love
to eat cake for breakfast but I know I
shouldn't so I don't like I want to see
more but I know I shouldn't so I don't
want a great trailer perfect trailer
good teaser trailer we'll all be there
to see chapter two cuz they were there
to see chapter one and it was sweet
so the teaser trailer to it Chapter two
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]